Before we can add wearable features to
the sample, or any other code you might
have already, we need to get things
ready to make sure it works properly.
Firstly, make sure you're compiling
against the V4 support library.
Let's open up our build upgrader file,
which is contained here.
And if we scroll down,
it's important that you use this library
because many notification features
such as action buttons, large icons,
and Android Wear and auto support have
been added to the framework since then.
And most developers need
to support older devices.
The next thing we need to
do is make sure our notifications
are issued correctly.
We open up the main activity,
and go down to the bottom here.
It's important that we replace
the use of notification manager
with notification manager compact.
If you try to use notification manager
while supporting older API devices,
they'll lose any special
wearable extensions.
So this is the code
change to implement this.
We hit Alt + Enter to add
dependencies and then we're done